[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
LILIANE UMUBYEYI: Hi,
good morning, everyone.
I'm happy and honored to give
this introductory session
on reparations.
But before I start, I
would like to give you
my disciplinary perspective.
The concept of
reparations has been
studied from different angles
and different disciplines,
whether it's economy,
sociology, law, philosophy.
And I would like to give you
more details from where I speak
and I stand when I talk about
this concept of reparation.
So during my PhD dissertation,
I studied mobilization
of apartheid victims
in South Africa
before American and in
South African courts.
And within this dissertation,
I treated the question
of reparations, how this concept
was appropriated and used
by victims movements,
NGOs, lawyers,
and different groups of actors.
So I'm not-- and
after that, I work
for different NGOs and human
rights organizations mainly
in sub-Saharan Africa,
an organization,
which were which
were implementing
programs of reparations.
And at this stage, I'm
not going to give you
a presentation on the meaning
of the concept of reparations,
but rather, on how
this concept is used,
appropriated in different
contexts by different actors,
and what are the
concrete implications
of these multiple uses.
I'm going to I'm going to
share my screen with you.
I think it will be more
helpful since I have
different concrete examples.
OK, so we have--
I know you have just
read the text written
by Pablo De Greiff on the
concept of reparations
and on the distinction between
different contexts, where
the term of reparation is used.
In his text, Pablo De
Greiff makes the distinction
between international law,
where the concept of reparation
can take different forms.
He talks about restitution,
compensation, rehabilitation,
satisfaction, and guarantee
of non-repetition.
The other context in which the
term reparation is frequently
used, according to
Pablo De Greiff,
is the design of reparation
programs with massive coverage.
And he insists on the difference
between these different
contexts and
explaining how, one,
in the context of international
law, the concept of reparation
has a kind of juridical meaning.
Whereas in the second
one, the reparation
are apprehended much more
as a political project.
And I would like to stop
on this point to share
or to illustrate how these
distinctions or how different
appropriation of the
concept of reparation
play out in a
concrete case, which
is the case of apartheid victims
mobilization in South Africa.
I would start by this example
of our project victims
mobilization.
So as you know, at
the end of apartheid,
the South African government set
up a Truth and Reconciliation
Commission in charge of
telling the truth of the crimes
of apartheid, grant amnesty, if
certain conditions were made,
and proposing recommendations
for reparations.
The image on the
left illustrate one
of the session for the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission.
So this commission was
held between 1996 and 1998.
Some of the work
continued after,
but the main sessions were
held during that time.
And the South African Truth
and Reconciliation Commission,
which were interpreted apartheid
violence as human rights
violations related to
physical and integrity, and as
observed by Mahmood Mamdani,
and many other scholars
after this narrow interpretation
of apartheid violence
has the consequence
of putting aside
all the structural character
of apartheid injustices.
Not considering the
social economic violence
of the apartheid system, and
at the level of reparations,
this has a consequence
since there's
only a limited number of people
that were considered as victims
of apartheid that have been
given the status of victim
apartheid.
It's only 22,000 people
who could benefit
from individual reparations.
This small nuance that I
can bring on this aspect
is that, in the TRC, the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission,
the group was aware
that, of course,
apartheid involved much
more discriminations.
But people who have been
given the status of victims
and who could have access to
reparations were only 22,000.
In the early 2000,
in the early 2000,
a group of victims,
of apartheid victims,
decided to go to court
before American courts,
and that's the image that
we have on the right side.
They went to court, and they
sued multinational corporations
that were accused of having
aided and abetted the apartheid
regime.
In this trial, the victims
challenged the concept
of reparations that was
based on physical violence,
physical integrity, and
one of the main arguments
was to say that entire
communities were
affected by apartheid.
A system of discrimination.
Apartheid constituted a
system of discriminations
that affected every
aspect of the existence
of black populations from
the most intimate relations
with whom you could marry,
to the places where you could
study, where you could work,
where you could travel,
where you could live.
So this structural character
of apartheid, and consequently,
the reparations
cannot be individuals,
cannot be apprehended
at the individual basis.
They must take into account
this structural dimension.
So this lawsuit has been
brought into court in 2002
and stayed in court until 2015.
But it couldn't
go further because
of the legal proceedings
and all the challenges
of bringing a South African
case before American courts.
We could go further into
further details later on,
but I'm going to limit
myself here on this question,
on this aspect.
But what is important
here to keep in mind
on this aspect of reparations,
first of all, it is--
this case illustrates how it
is important to pay attention
on the concept, how the
concept of reparation
is approached and appropriated
by different actors,
whether it's state actors.
But we look, also, how
people, how movements, NGOs,
victims can formulate
and reformulate demands
in negotiating and negotiate
the sense of reparations.
So all that to say that
the meaning of reparation
is not something that
is fixed, that is rigid.
It's something that
evolves, and that
evolves over time,
and over space,
as we see here, for what
happens in South Africa,
and how it goes into
American courts.
And that is contested.
The second element that
this case highlights
is that, if we understand
the concept of reparation,
as it has been defined by
the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission, and
we will compare it
to how it is defined by victims
movements in the case of when
they go to American courts,
we can see that there
are concrete implications.
There are significant,
concrete implications.
Because, on one case,
we have 22,000 people
who have access to reparations.
Whereas in the second case,
their argument was to say,
if we take into account the
multiplicity of discrimination
that were inherent to
the system of apartheid,
then we have to
reconsider the number
of people who are victims and
who have access to reparations.
We can see that behind this
maybe abstract definition,
there are significant
differences and concrete steps
that are important.
I would like to move
to a second case, which
is the link, a second
case, but which
highlights the importance
of the significance
of the link between the
qualification of violence
and reparations.
In other words, what kind
of violence can be repaired,
what kind of violence
can be repaired?
And what kind of victims
have access to reparations?
The most significant or
the most telling case
in this regard for me concerns
the demand for reparations
expressed by Namibia,
and the Ovaherero, Nama
in some communities to Germany.
Reparations or
demanding reparations,
which had been
expressed concerning
the genocide against
those populations
at the beginning of
the 20th century.
The process of claiming
this reparation
began in 2005 with
interested discussions
between Germany and Namibia.
And for a very
long time, Germany,
but also, other
former colonial powers
have been advancing the
inter- temporal principle.
So this is a principle in
international law, which
stresses that a state is
responsible for violation
of international law only, if,
at the time of the violation
or of its continuing
effects, the state was
bound by the legal
provision it transgressed.
Well, in other
words, and this is
the argument, which has
been given by Germany.
They, at the time of--
at the time the
genocide was committed,
they were not violating
any international law.
And, therefore,
there's no obligation
to provide reparations.
This argument has been used by
Germany and is still, somehow,
being used by Germany.
But it also-- it has also been
used by many former colonial
powers.
Here, you can see the image here
at the Durban Conference, which
is the conference, one
of the biggest conference
organized by the
United Nations in 2001,
20 years ago, on racism.
And when many states expressed
the need for reparations
within this conference,
the response
of many colonial and
former colonial powers
was to advance this principle.
However, some
scholars, and I think
that is also the case for
the UN Special Rapporteur
on the question of reparations.
It is to say that
there is an exception.
There is an exception if direct
consequences of these acts
extend into a time when the
act and its consequences
are considered
international [INAUDIBLE]..
For example, that means that
we could not use this for them
in their interpretation.
We cannot use this principle
for racial discriminations, now,
because they are the
consequences of these facts
that happened at a time, where
a state had no international
legal obligation.
Because we have direct ongoing
consequences of this fact.
This case, for me--
this case, for me,
it's illustrative
of a different important,
significant points.
The first point that
I want to insist upon
is that the moment when
the facts happened,
the facts for which people
are asking for reparations
or reparation claims are made,
that moment is fundamental
since it determines, whether
a state can be liable
on the basis of international
law and as reparations.
This is the first key element.
The second element, what
this case is illustrative of
is the paradox faced by
reparations movements since,
in order to demand--
the paradox is that they have
to use tools international--
if they use
international law, they
are constrained
to a legal system.
And with its limits
and principles,
which has rendered possible,
the colonial system.
So they have to operate
in a system that
was at the basis of the
colonial phenomenon,
and to challenge that system on
the basis of that legal system
is quite constraining
and imposes
of the number of limits.
And this leads me to my third
point that I would like to--
the third and last point that
I would like to share with you.
I would even say a question.
So if we think that
international law is limiting
because of certain principles
that have been set up
at a moment where colonialism
was prospering, if we think
that it's limiting, then,
what kind of model of justice
should we use or could we use if
we want to ask for reparation?
What could be the alternative
to international law?
One of the cases that could
be that is interesting
here is the case of
reparations in Canada.
So before I address the
image in the dissertation
that you see here, I would
like to just give you
a little bit of background.
So as you may know, from the
late 19th century to 1996,
the government of
Canada operated
the Indian residential
school system
with the goal of assimilating
indigenous children
by stripping them of their
traditions, customs, values,
languages.
And the children were subjected
to different physical abuses,
sexual and emotional abuses.
And in the early '90s, former
students of this system
decided to litigate to ask for
reparations to the government,
but also, to the churches that
were involved in this system.
And they denounced in a
lawsuit, and this lawsuit
led to a settlement
with the government,
a settlement of $5 billion.
And that settlement also
involved reparations,
which were not only
financial reparations,
but also, the acknowledgment of
the past wrongs, compensation,
rehabilitative
measures, including
physical and
psychological health
services, legal services,
educational support,
and the establishment of
the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission.
And the chief investigator
involved in the negotiation
of this settlement has explained
that it was possible --
That settlement was only
possible by setting aside
conventional legal
frameworks of tort
and civil law in favor
of indigenous law
and legal traditions,
and my point here
is to show what can be
achieved, if we decide,
if we follow alternative
paths to international law.
And for me-- and this is
more a question and, I think,
something that we we'll address
in the different workshops
or the different presentation
that will follow in the modules
is to understand what extent
the transitional justice
framework could be useful in
addressing, or responding,
or addressing colonial
violences, injustices.
Colonial, but also, slavery.
Why do I bring this question of
transitional justice framework?
I think about transitional
justice framework,
because the original idea behind
transitional justice is that
legal practitioners..
And that's in the late '90s.
Some legal practitioners
expressed the need
to question the centrality
of the criminal trial
as a way to respond
to mass violence,
and there was a desire among
these legal practitioners
to look at the
mechanisms that were
used in different mechanisms
for resolving conflicts
in the African states,
in Asian states,
South America, but non-Western,
a non-Western concept
of seeking individual
responsibility.
And there were-- and
within this interrogation
emerged the idea of
using some concept
and mechanisms, the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission.
Of course, that was the
original idea in the '80s.
But after that, the
transitional justice framework
has evolved and has come
to include criminal trials.
I'm not here to say
if it's a good--
I mean, if it's a
good or bad evolution.
But we know that the
field has evolved, and has
come to include this evolution,
and has come to be much more--
it's much more used by
international organizations,
NGO, United Nations, with
all the technicalities
that it involves.
But at the beginning
of this interrogation,
there was the need to
question the centrality
of the Western use of trials.
Yeah, what I found
interesting in these debates
about reparation and about
reparations for colonialism
is to see if these models
that are, most of the time,
used in the global
South, if they
can be used to rethink the
way we think about trials,
the way we think about
litigation regarding
colonialism and slavery
in the Western societies.
So all this to say that
the concept of reparation
is not a--
it's not something--
I mean, to conclude, it's
not something that is rigid.
It's not something that
has a fixed meaning.
It's something that is evolving
over time and over space.
But it is also a
concept that is evolving
in the midst of
many transformations
of international law, of
transitional injustice,
of other mechanisms and
practices that are also
inherited from the history of
the legal systems and practices
of the resolving conflicts.
Yes, so that's it.
I think that we can dig.
We can go deeper into some
aspects within the Q&A
and, of course,
within the modules.
Thank you.